is tax evasion are we good with that or
no no not at all you have to pay your
taxes I you have to pay your taxes first
of all Every American does some form of
tax evasion which is crazy yeah like
there's everybody all the way to the
foot yeah now you guys are all going to
jail okay I yeah I'm working with 87 000
new IRS agents actually oh yeah
undercover no I mean taxes are important
man it sucks that it like goes to
[ __ ] blowing up brown kids in like uh
Yemen the way I see it is that it still
is like a fraction of it it's still
going to schools Rose like that fraction
yeah fraction yeah I mean it's still
it's still those are incredibly
important you know the the Trump uh the
Trump bucks the stimmies that was great
for the first time ever every American
was like wait a minute the government's
like kind of got my back a little well
they're like oh it's inflation you gave
poor people money yeah wow you can't
print that much money without inflation
happening but most of the money wasn't
printed for the poor most of the money
was printed for the stock market yeah